three and a half years after the release
of breath of the wild
this just dropped out of nowhere what's
up guys mass nintendo bandit here and
i'm going to contain my hype long enough
for us to actually break this down and
talk about it we're going to cover some
questions at the end so be sure to stay
tuned until after i break down the
trailer so it starts out with this
familiar fade into the tapestry cutscene
but it looks like it's been beautifully
re-rendered
as far as i can tell this is not a
re-recording of these lines from impa's
voice actor
it sounds the exact same so this is most
likely just a re-rendering of this
legend probably to the opening of the
game
and speaking of re-renderings there are
also just completely new
animations and settings looks like they
spared no expense for the creation of
100 years ago hyrule everything looks
gorgeous and very true to the original
but it just really captures just the
horror of what happened 100 years ago
when
all of the shika constructs were turned
evil by calamity ganon
and they assaulted hyrule this is going
to be before
any of those events as evidenced here by
this little time skip
obviously we see the gorgeous hyrule
castle that just looks
really quite spectacular in all of its
old glory and we also see a bunch of
birds flying through the air now these
birds are actually pretty large from
what i can tell
so my first instinct is thinking i mean
either these are rito or
loftwings if they were loftwings that
would be super cool because we have not
ever seen
live loftwings outside of skyward sword
and breath of the wild did have a whole
bunch of connections to skyridge sword
although i'm not sure how they would
have gone extinct but maybe we'll get
more of that in the game
next up we have a pretty good shot of
link raising his sword and allegiance
most likely to the king of hyrule or
maybe even princess zelda but one thing
to note here is that this is before he
was chosen as a champion i'm assuming
because he's not wearing his champion
garb and he doesn't have the master
sword yet but yet he is in the hylian
soldier gear
and because we do see link with the
master sword later on the trailer this
is going to cover
how he initially found the master sword
which is super exciting
then we have a shot of zelda just
walking in the castle you know being
zelda
and then we have this glory shot of
warfare
in this new hyrule warriors game if
you're familiar with hyrule warriors you
know that there's a lot of foot soldiers
a lot of enemies covering all of the
ground
but seeing that in the familiar
territory of breath of the wild's hyrule
is just really special especially
because we can pick up on some of the
bigger
weapons that probably both sides will be
using against each other like the hylian
cannons
and potentially enemy catapults but more
on that later we then see zelda and mifa
discussing the sheikah slate which is
pretty important because this means that
zelda has
a sheikah slate and the reason why
that's important i'll get into in just a
second
here we can see what can only be assumed
to be link and rivali sparring off
which given rivali's character is
probably pretty typical
i'm assuming he's the one who challenges
link in the scenario but it also looks
like he actually gets the better of link
which is something that you wouldn't
assume to have happened given what we
see in the original game
either way this scene is super
interesting and i'm not sure if maybe
link activates like his slow motion
ability and maybe turns around
and gets out of this or what but either
way it does look like rivali has a
one-up on link here
it is definitely possible that they're
actually just fighting a different enemy
but i don't think that's the more likely
scenario because it looks like rivali is
dodging link's strike pretty clearly
then of course we have a shot of ganon's
army approaching the castle
and this is the part that is pretty
interesting to me we see
that as part of link's moveset he throws
a bomb now this makes sense since its
breath of the wild link and in the
previous hyrule warriors games they
definitely pull in weapons and
characters from all
over the place and just kind of smash
them all in the same game i mean
even link's spinner from twilight
princess is a weapon but in this case
because we're not sure if this game is
canon yet
link can't use that kind of weaponry
without a sheikah slate
that bomb is shika technology but zelda
has the sheikah slate could this mean
that there are actually multiple or at
least there used to be then we have a
shot of the king of hyrule
bolstering his forces into battle and
immediately after that we see the
mechanics of those giant weird chica
pillar things that surround the castle i
mean you wouldn't have guessed but it
looks like guardians actually pop
out of the orifices i guess in the sides
of these things which kind of begs a few
questions and maybe even gives a few
answers about the mechanics of these
giant storage devices i mean are they
filled completely with
ancient energy it would kind of seem so
given what we see here or does it
literally create
guardians definitely an interesting
little tidbit to see
and show in a trailer and then we see
what can only be assumed to be
link's knighthood or rather his choosing
of being
zelda's appointed knight because again
he doesn't yet have his champion garb on
but yet this is definitely a special
environment here
zelda seems to be presenting link and
even imba at least i assume that's imp
annealing by him
looks like she used to be a little bit
taller this is probably just when zelda
was appointing both of these people
to work with her personally one as her
knight and one as her chief scientist we
then see some shots of hylian cannon
fire
most likely from right around the castle
some stall enemies rising from the
ground in response to calamity ganon's
power a lionel being a lynel oh and
again
as part of zelda's moveset she can also
use like the time
paws ability from the sheikah slate
meaning both link
and zelda have sheikah slates in this we
see mifa being pretty awesome using that
trident in battle which is something
i've always wanted to see personally and
a yiga invasion of gerudo town this is
something that wasn't mentioned at all
that i can remember in the original
breath of the wild the yiga hideout is
also in the gerudo desert area but i'm
not sure why they would attack gerudo
town
we know that eventually they go on to
steal their helmet and link has to get
it back
but this was far before then we have a
pretty fantastic glory shot of all the
champions which
i will admit is some pretty great
wallpaper material and a shot of
roudania the divine beast
we will most likely be seeing the fall
of the divine beasts in this game and
that means we would probably be seeing
the deaths of the champions as well
we see a bokoblin just completely waste
this zoro knight and to be honest with
you i'd never realized but goblins were
that big
a little tidbit of darunia's moveset
which looks really cool
same thing with rivali looks like he's
got some spray fire and then this scene
happens very quickly in classic breath
of the wild teaser trailer style
and what this looks like to me is link
blocking an attack
from some sort of lightning weapon he
already has his champion's garb
and the master sword which does prove
that we're going to see
his gaining of the master sword in this
game but judging from the type of weapon
used and the angle that the weapon's
coming down at him from
and the fact that it looks like a
lightning blade i'm assuming he's
battling a lionel since they're known to
use lightning weaponry sometimes and i
can only assume it's coming from way
above his head
and it looks like he actually parried
this attack which is pretty cool and
then we see
very quick snippets back to back of the
champions either getting hurt
being surprised or narrowly dodging an
attack
this is probably what i can only assume
to be their deaths then we see an
explosion happen on a wall
in front of lincoln zelda on what can
only be assumed to be the day of
calamity ganon's rebirth the fact that
there was an explosion in front of them
but then they turn around means it was
probably
shot at them from catapult fire most
likely from the moblins
in the distance we can see hyrule castle
town meaning this is an assault on the
gates itself
we can also see the very metallic gates
from breath of the wild and then we see
the very familiar scene of calamity
ganon roaring in the face of the blood
moon
but after the logo we get one more
little shot
we get to see zelda using her power in a
place that we haven't seen in the
original game
it looks like she's indoors with what
looks like stone walls around her but
she's also in the goddess dress
since she's already crying and nobody
else is around her and she's using her
power this can only mean one thing
this is zelda holding off against
calamity ganon in
the castle this is the final moment
before the 100 year time lapse the final
moment of the game
and after that we get the release date
which is november 20th which is pretty
soon also in the wallpaper art that pops
up after that there's some sort of
little
cute baby guardian type thing that i can
only imagine how we're going to be able
to meet and
even use in the game so i'm really
excited about this
okay guys that was the breakdown so now
let's talk about a few things
first and foremost the glaring question
is this game going to be canon well as
aunuma stated before the trailer hit he
specifically asked the creators of
hyrule warriors to make the story of a
hundred years ago
my first instinct is to say that since
this was directly asked from aonuma to
tell the story of breath of the wild
how can this not be canon some aspects
of the gameplay might not be but i mean
come on
there's no way that it's not which for
theorists like me
is really really good news there's a lot
more material coming
and also another question that most
people had immediately myself included
is
is this breath of the wild 2 the answer
of which is no
absolutely not again aonuma states that
they are currently in development of
breath of the world 2 and we have no
news on it currently
just an update that development is still
happening which is good that he even
said that because some nintendo fans
were beginning to lose faith but i
digress
this is a breath of the wild 1.5 if you
will it's kind of a prequel to breath of
the wild and when the sequel comes out
breath of the wild will be the first
ever zelda trilogy so guys there's
plenty to be excited about and if you
want other people to be excited please
drop a like on this video to get it
spread around so that the hype can keep
building and spreading
enough with this nintendo negativity
it's time to bring on the good times
and also guys i got a bunch of breath of
the wild theories on the channel if you
want to check those out and we can kind
of see if some of them come true when
the game releases be sure to subscribe
to stick around for a lot of the
coverage of this game and
everything nintendo and that's all i got
for you guys i'm off to go watch this
trailer about a hundred more times
and i'm sure some of you are gonna do
the same this is mass intended bandit
signing out
keep the hype real
[Music]
you